[Music]
in jackass news
I missed that show jackass Johnny
Knoxville great show
submitted by Joe malian vice president a
who is my best president a 5 mm abort
and I thought it was a dictatorship I
don't know there was president I didn't
think so no bar is the official minister
of torture Oh trees a very creative
creative field yeah
secretary secretary Energy Secretary of
Energy I think about this thing God's
answer enough I mean with a power plant
yeah like preparing the society oh shoot
we didn't even need that but I think we
need it now yeah do you think about it
does not even say it's right now it's
fine you meant like energy doesn't like
vibes
well yeah you kind of do the patriarchy
is really strong in this organization
anyway there are females in leadership
roles yes the secretary the secretary
yeah I thought you were secretary of
fake boyfriend's mysteriously fake
boyfriends I don't have a fake boyfriend
she said she was my favorite 15 teens
have been treated for rabies after
alleged sexual contact with an infected
donkey this Wow
did they [ __ ] the donkey this [ __ ]
sick piece of [ __ ] like in South America
they had it look at their dicks thank
you for opening your mind to the teen
teens does that mean that they all [ __ ]
this one donkey or one guy [ __ ] a
donkey which [ __ ] another person
another teen and just went down at him
maybe it was a donkey train yeah they
probably passed the donkey around why
did they leave the donkey donkeys [ __ ]
too cuz they don't know that they wanna
[ __ ] [ __ ] for survival because it's been
proven it's also been proven that
donkeys get wet they're exactly
don't have sex my pleasure that's
[ __ ] dolphins
I don't know I watched a documentary
where a guy was claiming like he knows
when a dog is horny what are these guys
credentials please and what's they a
toothless man in Bolivia
that's his current oh I'm sorry have you
ever looked at your dog and been like oh
he really likes me or he you know he
really likes this my dogs don't [ __ ] me
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
really oh his favorite is roast beef and
you don't know you can read their
emotions ah no because he'll show you
that that's his favorite because you'll
want to eat the roast beef versus the
dried dog that's why does the donkey run
away all the kids is [ __ ] on how you
know the donkey doesn't show the ass
like I do like dick human dick is cool
why are all donkeys the same I think
it's a girl donkey that they're doing it
with I don't think it's a boy dog what
does it matter how do we know that its
identifies as a growler guys read all I
need to hear about this [ __ ] donkey
sex of the donkey
what are the sex of the humans it seems
to be boys okay of course how different
is the donkey vagina and the in the
human female locations out pretty solid
like a good viscosity watch this other
dog he [ __ ] documentary I did see a
donkey [ __ ] documentary otherwise
he's it another way this one was it was
like a rite of passage
for these boys in this little village
and it was highly encouraged by the
older men in this village and they're
like you know what before you get with
the woman you need you need a practice
with the donkeys was it donkey tied up
no they just go up in a donkey's but the
thing is the doc he's like are just used
to it
they've been [ __ ]
many times it's like and some donkeys
like to be tied up the dog Wassily shut
uh that's [ __ ] some of the guys in
this town they they're so used to
donkeys that they're like yeah I got a
wife but you know what for all my life I
just been doing donkeys and I think I
prefer donkeys more than you know more
STDs that way cuz I don't think the dog
is cleaning them so no no girl
what documentary was this it's super
high risk you it's because everyone's
coming in this doll well they might be
coming in to the donkeys no it's the
same [ __ ] donkeys have surprising I
hate to get all science-y on you
I said they have great drainage you
saying everyone's coming all these
[ __ ] facts about his daughter
zombies have a high immunity system I
don't think it's just one sacred donkey
getting [ __ ] I think it's like
practice donkeys everywhere I know but I
feel like this town probably has three
to five donkeys know there's probably 37
37 and like 250 men like honestly I feel
like that's what's going on there's
actually more doggies event I feel like
the elder trans men are like yeah so
it's a rite of passage like they're
[ __ ] around yeah yeah and the kids
are just like okay and it [ __ ] went
bad cuz nothing all [ __ ] loved it
yeah that's true that sometimes pretty
cool gone sexual organs actual lungs you
[ __ ] gone wrong teenagers 15 oh
there's 15 [ __ ] nasty little strings
so they're actually saying that it could
be more because there there were there
are many families that took their sons
outside of the area to go get treatment
at hospitals okay they got rabies from
doc you [ __ ] from a low
called donkey it was a decent oh yeah
did not give consent I guarantee it
but what does the donkey wasn't he Julia
and trust me a note offensive donkey was
very attractive and was flirting pretty
hard they do have really long eyelashes
what was the donkey wearing very curious
where this china time order Wisconsin
Canada Canadians [ __ ] donkey gotta be
the US look at South America it was in
rule Morocco Morocco oh it's a maracas
donkey that's understand got it
those Moroccan donkeys are hard to
resist huh sure they're the finest of
donkeys yeah yeah so apparently they
took these infected boys to the hospital
and they had to spend a week there to
receive medication of rabies
vaccinations yeah you're in there and
you're like yeah so I was you know I
haven't sex with the donkey and I think
I might have contracted something like
how does that conversation go and did
they [ __ ] the donkey er that a donkey
give them a [ __ ]
that's not correspond saying you would
secure dick and a donkey mouth nope I
would stick my dick in a donkey what if
it licks it it's not [ __ ] that's
looking yeah I don't have a dick so I
don't know a differential what it feels
like oh how come girls don't get that
curious we're not animals they can [ __ ]
anytime they want well cuz you know how
like guys like that's a good point this
happens a lot like guys like trying to
[ __ ] other animals and things and just
do my buddy said that he would push to
and this sounds like I'm Dishonored tell
us for a bow myself I'm fine with that
but he would push - couch cushions
together
it's nothing someone we know good I
tried it
I tried it what didn't feel good yeah he
said England after the fourth pump maybe
mm-hmm a bit before you get to four
pumps then maybe like have you ever as a
girl had a wet dream like were you like
orgasm didn't your dream in your sleep
now I wish okay see I had those dreams
but it's only when I like having sex
with a tree I'm like bubble waterfall
like you're just rubbing up against the
tree yes the treetops no trees not going
to me it's like a dry hump it's like a
dry County you must like camping
I don't know it's always like it's like
a tree [ __ ] brillo pad free voice
it's okay Niki you'll see [ __ ]
Pocahontas both of you share that weird
day I'll tell you one of my weirdest one
I'm never I don't think I've ever told
anyone this dream but I had this one
dream when I was in this bathtub I know
there was a whole bunch of like fruits
in it I was like in a bathtub with what
kind of fruit like strawberries like
okay something like smoke do you see
that I don't know where I just start
like just getting really turned on and
stuff and next thing I know I look down
and Bill Cosby like down there going to
town before after a fool still raping
and dreaming he goes he goes dad at his
way in your bathtub it was pretty good
he has years of experience of amazing oh
yeah I don't know especially with
unconscious women which is what you are
the time ya know just rip it out I'm
like why the bathtub I know what to get
you for Christmas
I was like that's all well that's what I
want to say after being with Bill Cosby
by the way
so it's oh my god that is crazy
you got dream raped by Bill Cosby raped
she likes it
I mean ya didn't say no in the game yeah
throw the fruits out it was he you in
the fruit it was like a bats of of fruit
and I just did his head like that's
honestly scarier than the clown head his
head thank you seeing you out with a
papaya next did I ask was he was he
doing like The Cosby no dirty dog
Oh God that's his face right yeah I was
I was horrified when I woke up like oh
my God why did I and that sucks cuz you
said you [ __ ] came but then then
you're horrified that's so confusing I
know that's why I woke up so confused
happy besides morning Jim I preferred
the tree actually yeah I think you're
gonna hope you guys enjoyed that video
but if you didn't guess what you can
directly contribute to the articles that
we discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hi
[Music]